people keep talking about how remote
work is part of the future of work well
I have news that future is here remote
and hybrid work are the new reality and
now we have to figure out how to make
them work for all of us
in March 2020 when the covet pandemic
hit remote work went into hyperspeed
work routines that were tied to commutes
and buildings where people share time
and space went away many people wondered
what would become of teamwork
collaboration and productivity they soon
found that they could accomplish more at
home and find the best work-life
flexibility of their careers today the
verdict is in using surveys polls and
meta-analyzes I found that over 70
percent of employees in most Global
surveys want a mix of in-person and
remote formats moving forward this makes
us multimodal workers what does this
mean it means we have to be awesome in
person we have to be awesome remotely
and we have to be awesome when we're in
hybrid mode while that might sound like
a lot with some new thinking and new
skills we can use the office as one of
our many work tools I've been doing
research and advisory work work on
distributed work for over 20 years and
have spoken with over 300 companies
around the world here are four things we
know work well first coordinate anchor
days when we go to the office let's make
sure we overlap with our colleagues and
collaborators that's why we call these
anchor days otherwise we'll find
ourselves in the office with no one
around no use in gathering at the water
cooler if we're the only ones there
second plan spontaneity in my work I've
heard over and over again that while
people prize the flexibility of hybrid
work they long for informal and
spontaneous interactions with their
colleagues this is a classic Paradox but
it's quite solvable through what we call
structuring unstructured time one thing
to try is to set aside the initial six
to seven minutes of an hour-long meeting
for informal chat about non-work matters
just to talk or even complain you can
also ask people the one word that
describes how they're doing verbally or
intact you can have informal contact by
scheduling virtual or in-person lunches
with your colleagues breaks for coffee
tea or a snack and even happy hour
trivia challenge if you're a leader you
should demonstrate the value of informal
talk by initiating it yourself third use
the right tools to communicate the key
here is to match our digital tools with
our communication objectives which means
we have to mix it up if we have to solve
a really complicated problem the best
digital tool to use is one that allows
real-time discussion if we need to
process complex information sending an
email might be the best option giving
people time to review and absorb the
content video can be great when we need
our communication to include emotional
cues it helps to see someone's face when
discussing tricky topics it also
increases immediacy and intimacy but it
can be exhausting many people reporting
Tech exhaustion but it doesn't have to
be that way we need to know when to take
a break for one-on-ones try audio and
keep the cameras off this last takeaway
is for management but it affects all of
us commit to the new culture top leaders
have to avoid sending mixed messages too
many are saying they're all for hybrid
while signaling that they prefer
everyone to be in the office or saying
this conversation is so important we
should have it in person leaders need to
make sure that their words actions and
attitudes are aligned with the hybrid
Arrangements that they've chosen
consistency between hybrid policies and
attitudes is the only way to build an
inclusive hybrid culture for everyone